welcome to this video playing
international master DeMarcus I have one
draw against him no name in them yet
very high rating and earlier to six and
five minute I'm just really really high
okay let's see what line we get in the
Spanish do I have to play my old she
going I'm going to do something else I
don't know yet what I will do but ok is
playing this anyway deform that's not
bad different line the Yates variation
leading to an interesting play now d 5
or Bishop b3 is what white is normally
doing c6 if i'm not mistaken yep like it
goes all the way back there is an
interesting line actually for white I
think not not that it is leading to an
edge if that would be the case everybody
would play it but it leads to yeah this
is this is interesting this is
interesting interesting position type
looks more like a Sicilian then then
then a rillo pass in a way but yeah it's
kind of it's it's interesting to play
try to keep control here over ok once
wants to go chat 5 I don't know how
dangerous that is maybe it is actually
night at five and queen of three I
should have should have done something
about this no es Queen f3 this is very
annoying Queen night h6 is a huge
problem
yeah that's really really ugly but okay
the he threatens this nothing I can do
he threatens night h6 and arguing long
about this move is also not helping very
much maybe it's not so terrible I mean
he has got two nights there on h4 in f5
it's not not super clear if they are
more than an annoyance on or really
really dangerous I can't try to try to
play quickly here maybe it's not so bad
at least I'm pretty reliably controlling
the d5 square this is general very
important if you have problems on the
Kings and at end the g five squares is
off then it usually is this is
impossible almost impossible to play but
my central control more or less intact
it's it's maybe not not so terrible and
he's taking lots of time that's good
I don't I don't think you can play a
sacrificial attack there or something
yeah that's an interesting move looking
at a five going to stay with my policy
of quick moose I now get the a five
point I get the a five pawn or he has to
play before one of the two okay so he
wants to play aggressively i see with f5
probably coming and now i can still take
a five yeah I don't really what is this
idea taking their def five or I don't
know he has to show me this is I mean
okay i want this pawn but it's also
about night b3 it's not just that I
wanted to win a pawn that'd be three
might be quite useful and so he's just
quickly does it make some sense to take
on f5 I don't think so three honest I
don't really understand the attacking
idea here Bishop age six and then Queen
takes me five maybe you know we take 95
immediately hmm okay
I take here for rupee aid I mean pawn
takes rook e8 okay now here also rupee
aight i guess pushing the Queen back you
will threatening to take on age six and
he has to retreat i believe i also have
let's say play screen g3 i might go
before intending Queen takes f nights
not working Queen takes f5 is not
working what this is attacking idea that
we five probably as you fire it's before
good or not mm-hmm I cannot really play
f6 or something this looks really sick
okay I'm playing before whatever maybe I
can click with a five or something like
that the right moment getting the Queen
over okay thinking maybe a rook c8
trying for a counter play okay Queen a
true maybe harassing him what is the
what is he doing then
root be one less rupee aid now that's it
up I've winning one of those bishops you
can play some kind of desperate attack
out but okay i'm clicking this bishop
here so he's attacking on g 7 f-6 i
guess or what yeah I guess f6 is fine
right h4 is really not much more than a
check at the moment what is the ideal
Queen where
93 then or what exactly but then I have
Queen takes a form so i think i can take
actually ok open and now is there
anything queen d 7 this is also quite
good right i asked a group d 1 so this
is all right taking too much time you
actually ok so he's attacking here ok i
should just take here right this nothing
nothing threatened time warning
yeah so queens traded and then it turns
out on more time yeah I don't think I
played the opening well this is kind of
maybe age six was was a badge um
superficial move now I guess it is and I
don't hear this is this idea weakening
the light squares that looks that looks
a bit a bit shaky yeah does this doesn't
look like it should be done 23 was I
guess a bit more tricky here yeah but
maybe this is ok I mean I don't know
he's got those two nights there and I'm
not getting mated him now maybe I'm okay
the computer says about equal I had my
doubts really yeah now he went crazy a
little bit and played very very sharply
yeah okay I could have taken on a
forward this is also not bad I guess txt
and now we even give up the exchange I
think this is just not working the comp
wants to play Knight f3 f6 and back at
seven and says black a slightly better
yeah maybe I mean I want to pawn but you
might have some compensation which I
think here it's really not the case I'm
not sure about that move but I wanted to
get rid of one attacker rook e8 back
before that looks okay I think yeah I
think I'm just winning in am the compass
on minus 2 doesn't find anything so I
guess it was it was okay i don't like
them this age six moves so much with
hindsight but ok try to play the opening
a bit bit more bit more quickly okay
thanks for watching